foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 150x
wow yeah I know I know it's uh those
last digits of numbers get kind of
uppity they're a little bit reactionary
you better just replace them all with X
yeah X it's uh it's equal in its
treatment of uh genders and oh yeah the
whole thing is uh it's it's egalitarian
and uh very forward thinking I think you
ever feel like the entire planet has
jumped the shark yeah and it's it's got
to have been a big shark is my feeling
right space shark
giant space shark for example yep I
think so well it has been weird here
right it is it is uh this the storm that
is now beginning to wreak havoc on the
Midwest and is going to hit the East
Coast smacked us here in the Pacific
Northwest like we we had a ton of snow
it hasn't been just this morning it got
over freezing for the first time in four
or five days
uh and you know very very unusual for
here and then our pair went out so we
are
a little less prepared than we might be
but
I think Solstice two days ago Christmas
two days from now here we are in the
middle of it
we're gonna talk to you guys for a bit
we are hyper prepared rather than Ultra
prepared is my feeling no it's not no
it's really not my feeling but I thought
I'd try it out we've now explored it we
don't have to go down that road again
cool it didn't work nope slipping and
sliding the whole way yep with no uh
traction control of any kind yeah yeah
exactly okay well we're going to talk
about
um the Stanford bad word list and uh
some some trans stuff
and and the like today
excellent
yeah before that let's do some Logistics
shall we uh let's do that and I will
very subtly disarm my phone which I
realize I have left live dude nobody's
even gonna know that this is what I'm
doing all right no nobody can tell
um so we follow these live streams with
the Q a as our regular viewers and
listeners will know you can ask
questions at darkhorsesmissions.com and
we take about a 15 minute break between
the end of this and the beginning of the
Q a
uh we are live on Odyssey as well as
YouTube the chat is live on Odyssey not
active on YouTube
you are always encouraged to find more
of our thinking at 100 gatherers guys
the 21st century our book that came out
last year and uh despite uh a lot of
people's
hard work made it to the New York Times
bestsellers list I despite a lot of
people's hard work that is pretty much
how it looked yeah it really really felt
that way but um so a lot of people have
bought it I hope a lot of people have
read it and we certainly get a lot of
really cool food feedback feedback too
food back and there's uh there is time
to have it delivered uh before the final
days of Hanukkah or Christmas if you get
the audio version yes yes or the Kindle
version of the Kindle yeah the Kindle
version presumably as well because that
because it's very thin it derives yeah
very quickly doesn't make as good a
weapon against a home intruder if you're
just reaching around for something no
but it's easy to wrap
all right start wrapping oh yeah I'm not
going to I was freaking yeah I was I was
spelling it both ways in my head
um
you can also find my writing weekly at
natural
selections.substech.com this week I
wrote in part about some of what we were
talking about last week uh with regard
to that ridiculous piece of suitor
research that claims that 3.2 million
lives were saved by the vaccines without
actually introducing any new data or
revealing what estimates they relied on
um that told them that vaccines save
lives um but I also talked a bit about a
fair bit in this piece about the
Stanford the Stanford nonsense so we'll
talk a little bit about that today
you can it's too late to get uh any
merchandise for Christmas or Hanukkah I
assume but it's Christmas or Hanukkah
yeah or um
or
I don't know what you might celebrate
that would warrant like a gift that's a
long ways off Brett yes that's true
good on you for knowing that yeah I I I
okay the only reason we know that is
because some dear friends of ours uh
just uh just told us that they're having
a baby and the baby is doing Flag Day so
we are thrilled but there will be I
assume for some people gift giving
opportunities before the middle of June
yes I am assuming they planned it that
way I am assuming they did not deliver
you on Flag Day yeah it's hard it's hard
to plan these sorts of things as you
know
touche yes okay
um but you darkhorsestore.org has lots
of cool stuff that you could get for
flag Bay if you really wanted to but it
seems to me that's waiting a long time
and we are supported by you our audience
we appreciate you there for subscribing
to this main YouTube channel or the Dark
Horse podcast Clips YouTube channel or
the Odyssey channels uh or uh hitting
subscribe however you do wherever you
get your podcasts liking sharing uh both
the clips and the full episodes
and uh recognizing that if YouTube is
driving you crazy with the ads that's
really not on us because they are
putting ads on our stuff even though
they have demonetized us as of a year
and a half ago now uh even though the
stuff they've been monetized does for us
true yeah yeah well that wasn't
misinformation or disinformation the
most galling thing about it to them was
that it was true
right
if we had lied no big whoop but because
we spoke the truth wow yeah yeah surely
we're not uh that's not pleased not to
be allowed
um you can also uh Join one of our
patreons or we have uh conversations
every month
um on both of them and through our
patreons you can access our Discord
server or there's a fabulous community
of people who do things like have
karaoke hour so consider joining our
patreons and and joining the Discord
there and of course we have sponsors to
whom we are very grateful
they are helping us out a lot and we in
return only accept a sponsors companies
whom we actually really truly do vouch
for so without further Ado we will start
uh the hour with three ads as we always
do
starting with seed
our first sponsor this week is seed seed
is a company focused on bacteria and the
microbiome and they have a terrific
probiotic called ds01 daily synbiotic
s-y-n I always prefer eating real food
to taking pills but I have to say I love
this product I love the seed daily
symbiotic there are a lot of things that
you can do to enhance your health our
sign off here at Dark Horse includes
three of them of course we go to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside but a lot is hidden in those
words what for instance constitutes good
food good food is real food whole food
food that's been alive recently and was
grown with care and conditions as
ancient as possible given the
constraints of the 21st century but even
many people who eat such a diet end up
missing something in part because our
soils are impoverished due to you know
decades into centuries now of
agricultural practices that that take
the nutrients out of them we humans
contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which may harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them this is why probiotics can be an
important tool in a healthy lifestyle
even if you eat nutrient-dense food and
avoid processed foods and sugar
but not all probiotics are created
equally
seeds DSO one daily symbiotics a broad
spectrum two in one probiotic and
Prebiotic it contains 24 distinct
probiotic strains in a two-in-one
capsule that protects the probiotics
until they hit the colon where they are
most effective if you've taken a
probiotic before and it didn't do
anything for you it's probably because
the good bacteria weren't surviving your
GI tract see it is designed differently
with that two in one capsule and that
makes all the difference that's why it
works seeds daily symbiotic supports gut
skin and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 20 off off your
first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com Dark Horse and
use code Darkhorse
okay our second sponsor this week is
moink that's moo plus oink m-o-i-n-k and
this gets us into the eat good food man
is moink good food
an eighth generation farmer founded Mike
and is working hard to help save the
family farm and get its customers access
to the highest quality meat on Earth did
you know that 97 of the chickens served
in the U.S are dipped in chlorine while
Family Farms don't tend to do that and
certainly the meat you get from oink
doesn't
Mike delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild caught Alaskan
salmon direct to your door that is it
delivers meat
that when those animals were alive we're
eating the food that they were that they
evolved eating as opposed to some
hyper-processed food that contains lots
of ingredients that the animals have
spent no evolutionary time eating until
like yesterday moink farmers Farm like
our grandparents did as a result Mike
meeked wink meat tastes like it should
which is to say delicious unlike the
supermarket only gives you total control
over the quality and source of your food
you choose the meat delivered in every
box like rib eyes chicken breasts pork
chops salmon fillets and much more and
you can cancel anytime
we love everything about moink the fact
that the meat is grass-fed and finished
on small farms the lovely Publications
that come along with it and of course
the meat itself pork beef lamb chickens
it's all completely delicious consider
starting the new year or treating
someone else in the new year to some
truly fabulous meat grown humanely with
care and fantastic for you Shark Tank
host Kevin O'Leary called Monk's bake
and the best bacon he's ever tasted and
I agree it's amazing
keep American farming going by signing
up at moinkbox.com Dark Horse right now
and listeners of this show will receive
free filet mignon for a year that's one
year of the best filet mignon you'll
ever taste but for a limited time that's
m-o-i-n-kbox.com Darkhorse moinkbox.com
our final sponsor this week you will not
be surprised to know is MD hearing aid
MD hearing aid makes high quality
effective hearing aids for a tiny
fraction of what most hearing aids cost
and you can buy them directly from MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid was founded
by an EMT surgeon who made it his
mission to develop quality hearing aid
that anyone could afford most people who
need a hearing aid only require a few
settings so he removed several of the
less often needed components and cut out
the middleman MD hearing aid has sold
over a million units and it has a 45 day
risk-free trial money back guarantee
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus model is
water resistant in up to three feet of
water and you don't need a prescription
to get one you buy it directly from the
source where audiologists and licensed
hearing Specialists are available seven
days a week everyone can empathize with
what it feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a 10 testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and here's what
she said
she said with my particular type of
hearing loss a deep male voice in a
noisy room is the hardest situation for
me to hear and understand speech I wore
the MD hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced male in
a room with a lot of white noise the MD
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point of
under a thousand dollars I was amazed at
how effective they are
MD hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people people who might not otherwise be
able to afford high quality hearing aids
get Clinic level care for 90 less with
MD hearing aid go to mdhearingaid.com
and use the promo code Darkhorse to get
their new buy one get one deal a pair of
hearing aids costs just 149.99 plus
Darkhorse listeners receive a free extra
charging case a hundred dollar value so
head to mdhearingaid.com and use the
promo code Darkhorse to get their new
buy one get one deal a pair of hearing
aids for 149.99
awesome
one more thing to say about logistics uh
I guess two things we will be here uh
for the last day of the year we'll do a
live stream on New Year's Eve
uh regular time regular place
and there will also be one more guest
episode of Dark Horse releasing next
Wednesday probably should be an awesome
conversation you've already had it um
but I'm excited to listen to it so it's
a good one for sure so we do have two
more dark
I'm not supposed to say he's
I think it's okay I think our listeners
get it
dark he's if that's the way you
pluralize horses which obviously yes
yeah yeah it is
um
all right
let's talk first about the uh the the
new bad word list from Stanford oh hell
yeah hell yeah
so this is a a project that they've
actually been work Stanford has been
working on it's specific to the it
community at Stanford for about 18
months and we were just made aware of it
via Twitter
oh excuse me uh this point might be a
week ago you know several days ago and I
looked at it went well this is this is
crazy and I saved it thinking that I'd
write about it for my sub stack and by
the time I went back a couple days later
Stanford had put it made it private uh
Wall Street Journal though put out an
op-ed the same day and they've got a PDF
of the original document that is that is
revealed but let me just let me share a
few of a few of these things so
basically they are they are you can
actually you can share my screen if you
like here Zach so I it is it is obvious
that this is a form of Newspeak
um that this is this is akin to what is
going on in Orwell's 1984 and I have in
my sub stack this last week the
following quotations from 1984 in which
Winston the the protagonist in 1984 is
being lectured by a fellow employee of
the ministry of Truth mini true uh Sim
asks him do you know that Newspeak is
the only language in the world whose
vocabulary gets smaller every year
he follows that up with don't you see
that the whole aim of Newspeak is to
narrow the range of thought
and it is clear uh from this list that
Stanford has put out and which has now
gotten a lot of attention because Wall
Street Journal did this very brief op-ed
on it that indeed it is about
constraining people and constraining
thought
I will share a few of what a few of what
is on their now private site except Wall
Street Journal revealed it but here's
something what's on screen now and I'm
not going to read this whole thing is
just a screenshot from what is open to
the public still or at least it was a
few days ago when I published my sub
stack and it includes just the final
bullet point here small changes could
make a huge difference now if you've
ever seen heard or said an email domain
or IP address being whitelisted or
blacklisted these terms assign value
connotations based on color white equals
good and black equals bad an act which
is subconsciously racialized consider
using the words allow list and deny list
so I
have had enough frankly so I have said
here
okay you petty tyrants and narcissists
guess what not everything is about race
here I am quoting myself lightness and
darkness which are most simply described
by the colors white and black exist
without humans around to name them
furthermore we are primates the clate of
mammals that is evolved and how we
navigate our sensory World from being
largely olfactory look at most mammals
and you see how snouty they are we have
one right here on screen and we see
everything from neurologically to
sensorily a move within early mammals to
become more olfaction based and then a
move within primates to become more
Vision based with the frontation as our
eyes move forward in our heads and we
have binocular vision we are largely
visual okay that's what we are
we assess our world I continue in the
sub stack piece in Myriad ways but first
and foremost for most of us we do so by
sight in darkness we cannot see and so
darkness is more fraught it is actually
more dangerous to attempt to navigate in
the darkness everyone knows this you
know this
stop making everything about your
particular grievance and you might find
the world is a more expansive and
fantastic place to live in
seriously whitelist and Blacklist as if
everyone who is using terms white and
black is referring to people with dark
or light or dark-skinned color
yeah and um it's insane and we're also
not supposed to say things are insane
we're not supposed to say so no we're
not uh admittedly it has been some days
since I looked at this list but my sense
is that unlike the 1984 version the
policing of uh various perceived truths
here is about
um protecting all sorts of people who
might find themselves affronted by some
turn of phrase that does not uh properly
protect them from a disability for
example or
um some piece of phenotype uh and it's
uh it's Preposterous it's Preposterous
um oh go ahead no just I've got a few to
share but yeah yeah go ahead okay
um you can show my screen here again
Zach
um these are and I also I tweeted these
out too so those of you who were looking
at my Twitter these will be familiar to
you but they suggest instead of brown
bag consider using lunch and learn or
Tech talk why
historically associated with the brown
paper bag test that certain black
sororities and fraternities use to judge
skin color those whose skin color was
darker than the Brown Bag were not
allowed to join
brown bag is actually historically
associated with bags that are brown
because they're made of paper that's not
bleached which is actually a good thing
yes so that's one
um instead of abusive relationship
consider using relationship with an
abusive person why
because the relationship doesn't commit
abuse a person does so it is important
to make that fact clear
it's well because this is a pressing
societal issue the people are unsure if
it's the people or one of the people in
a relationship with the relationship
itself is that is causing the abuse so
rather than I don't know working to help
someone who is suffering abuse at the
hand of another person we're going to
police the language that's right this is
this is a beauty actually because one
can imagine right that were the
convention
corrected to this that somebody else
would decide that it was effective in
this configuration and that you know
that demonizing the idea of the
relationship when in fact it is a person
who has abused you in the you know the
relationship is a two-party uh
interaction right so you can the point
he's gonna have a snitch situation like
right right well and that's the point is
that this is really about power this is
about the power to cause you not to say
something in some normal way that you
would ordinarily say it and to force you
into some configuration that puts
somebody else's priorities front and
center in your your world view which um
as as people who have been faced with
many of these things that is exactly the
experience is
um you know you are creating a
transgression in order to demonstrate
that I will abide by your instructions
using the word transgression is probably
itself a transgression because it brings
to mind trans people and transgression
has a negative connotation and if you
put a negative connotation to people's
head heads associated with trans people
you're probably doing a transphobia yes
on the other hand right I mean were you
you were doing it
but you know the intent is irrelevant of
the uh the uh loons on the left have
instructed us and I would point out that
one could equally make the argument that
I was actually providing recognition for
Trans people in Gresham which is a
suburb of Portland it's spelled totally
differently oh is it yeah oh you and
your spelling again I know I know and
there's nothing I see nothing in the
Stanford list about those who are
spelling impaired incidentally so we
barely deserve what we get yeah okay
next one instead of long time no see
consider using I haven't seen you in so
long instead of no can do consider
saying I can't do it why
the phrase long time no see was
originally used to mock indigenous
people in Chinese who spoke pigeon
English and no can do also originated
from stereotypes that mocked non-native
English speakers
now there are a lot of things in English
that pick up on a lot of errors in
English usage by all sorts of people
including native English speakers
but the ones that we have to be aware of
are ones that have been named and called
out by those who are actually just
seeking power as you just said well
um yes I would point out actually as
we've been pointing out for years that
the purpose of language this may sound
far-fetched perhaps
um perhaps a a claim that cannot be
supported logically but I believe that
we could establish the purpose of
language is to convey meaning that's
more of your adaptive arm-waving
hypothesis
I think language is a mind virus really
ah did not see us going there but all
right languages of Mind virus yeah
that's uh that's gonna be an uphill
battle for you now I'm sure I shouldn't
say uphill battle though I'm not sure
why I shouldn't say uphill battle some
people don't have access to Hills Brett
some people oh because you're living at
the bottom of the hill you're fighting
uphill in some places is the place you
want to live but in some places it's not
the place not when you're in battle you
shouldn't you want to be at the top of
the hill so we would be highlighting a
disadvantage of people who live at the
bottom of the hill by pointing out the
struggles that they face on the way to
defeating the people at the time and
some people have never benefited from
being able to experience battle and so
won't be able to really understand what
it refers to and therefore should be
protected from their own Ignorance by
not having it mentioned and some people
live embattled without ever having
physically fought and we do we have a
lot of evidence of that we do not want
to denigrate the struggles that they
have faced by highlighting the fact that
they were not in fact violent right I do
though you do because those struggles
aren't as big as the ones who were
actually physically embattled sorry no
yeah next one instead of prostitute
consider using debase why
it unnecessarily correlates corrupt or
unworthy purposes with sex work
because you wouldn't want little girls
to get the idea that they shouldn't
aspire to being prostitutes should you
yeah I'm still old school this way I
probably would but I get your point I
actually was the one that angered me the
rest of this it's like are you kidding
me are you kidding me are you kidding me
this one
really we're going to protect the
reputation of people who have yes
unfortunately found themselves having to
make a living by selling their bodies
no no next one instead of submit
consider using process why depending on
the context the term can imply allowing
others to have power over you
I want to point out that this is from
the same people who talk about Kink
shape and uh and engage in BDSM and you
know like to really populate the wind
and don't want us to talk about
prostituting
because that might associate negative
things with with sex work but
we shouldn't use the word submit well
but from this but I
this this actually uh
puts us in a position to run a
hypothesis because the key feature of
all of these is not that anyone imagines
we are going to stop speaking in these
ways the point is they want to establish
a rule in order that they can choose to
enforce it or not enforce it depending
upon whether the person who is speaking
is one they wish to enable or hobble
it's the low posted speed limit and low
posted speed limits as I understand as
I've learned from you I believe having
been a racist tool especially in the
South such that uh you know police
officers who were on the speed beat
could choose whether or not to pull you
over if you were breaking the law and if
the posted speed limit was really lower
than the road demanded almost everyone
was going to be going over it and then
they could choose to pull over the
people usually the dark-skinned people
who they wanted to give tickets to and
harass so this is this is a modern
version of a low posted speed limit it
is a modern version of low posted speed
limit and actually I would point out
that given that this list is
seemingly or nominally intended to
protect a wide range of people from
linguistic slights I'm going to claim
that this is the Stanford prism
experiment
okay good yes oh yes the Stanford prism
experiment experiment man you're the
best oh wow yeah this is a great moment
I'm enjoying this I no longer remember
what we're talking about but I feel good
about it uh well you're about to
remember because here's another one
instead of seminal consider using
leading or groundbreaking why because
this term reinforces male dominated
language
right
now I would point out okay
um
I think two is probably offensive but
many can play at this game you said you
were about to re-remember you are going
to be remembered we remember and I
believe that what you said is offensive
to people who stutter
re-remember you see what I'm saying yeah
you don't you don't have any comment on
seminal
I mean it kind of speaks for itself it
does I my my position on Twitter was
that now they're just being hysterical
whoa yeah okay I'll give you my screen
back here for a minute because I got two
more to show that actually
um came out of the site directly but I
just want to find them here okay uh you
can you can put my screen back on this
is just a PDF again of Wall Street
Journal collected the Stanford list that
is um that is now not public except that
Wall Street Journal did it for them so
they also say instead of using spirit
animal which like I've never thought
that was a particularly interesting way
of describing anything as a zoologist it
feels like really what huh okay but
instead of spirit animal say favorite
animal or animal and mostifier or would
like to be
why the term refers to an animal spirit
that guides and protects one on a
journey so to equate it with an animal
one likes it's to me and the
significance of the term
not to mention all the other animals
well no if their point is like no spirit
animal is a real thing and you're being
culturally appropriative and taking it
from the people who really actually have
spirit animals which no
frong don't exist
uh can I can I do this though
I feel
people
in the past who were not bewildered by
this kind of nonsense are my spirit
animal is that can I do that and how
would I refer to them
those people people who were not
confused this way
well I think it sounds like you want to
refer to them it's your spirit animal I
do want to okay done and okay but is
that not in and of itself
my defense
because them being my spirit animals
I get to not be confused in the way that
the people who made this list apparently
are yeah maybe maybe
um okay one more I'm gonna scroll wait a
second okay I think you I think you came
up with it before did I yeah what if not
being confused is my Kink then these
people are shaming me right not cool oh
yeah see I think I I uh I found the
loophole yeah yeah not being a
number
is my cake
I'm just preferring to the cookies guys
yeah yeah yes as far as I know that's a
50 something that's been a while yeah
it's probably something else too okay um
and finally this is this is
interestingly
um the one that got a lot of play
because I think the Wall Street Journal
um put it in its headline and a lot of
people went on about it instead of using
American consider using U.S citizen the
context is this term often refers to
people from the United States only
thereby in City waiting to the us as the
most important country in the Americas
which is actually made up of 42
countries now the thereby insidian that
the US is the most important country in
the Americas bit is silly
um
but this apparently Stanford has
apparently taken this and only this off
their list really it's the one that I
looked at and I was like yeah we all get
this if we've traveled right and yet
there's people and I think I'm not gonna
name them but there's people who are
recognized and very smart and highly
educated
um who have said no one has ever
objected to the word American like in a
like a blog post like no one has ever
objected to this like have you ever been
to Latin America because actually
I think
every time certainly that we were there
in in any place in Latin America and in
Mexico or Central America and
um it may it may have happened Less in
South America but certainly in in like
mesoamerica and Central America and
Mexico
uh when people ask you where you're from
if you say in response uh I'm an
American Americano Americana
um they look at you funny like yes so am
I so you didn't answer where you're from
so you know Estados I'm from the United
States isn't a what are you
um but you know people appreciate you
answering Norte Americano which also
isn't very precise because obviously it
includes Canadians and Mexicans but like
this one as much as like I'm not going
to stop referring to myself as an
American when I'm in America when I'm in
the United States of America this is
actually there is a point here unlike
almost all the right and there are a few
others for which there's points here
like there are really offensive terms on
this list that no one uses anymore who
like on the screen here half breed who
calls anyone a half breed of this boy
like we got over that right like those
who did that are not using that language
anymore right there is language that has
been understood to be actually racist in
that case and they don't say that
anymore
the fact that Stanford took American off
the list and didn't take uh for um
I can't even remember some some of the
gender stuff is completely insane uh
suggests that all they're doing all
they're doing responding to publicity
they have not investigated their
positions at all they are just trying to
get the Wall Street Journal off their
back and a few other people who didn't
spend time looking through the whole
list and just went like what America I'm
going to call myself an American I'm
like yeah so am I but recognize that
when you're in Guatemala and you say I'm
an American you may be met with usually
kind response it's like yeah I am too
you still haven't told me where you're
from
the funny thing is that in practice in
Latin America
everybody who is
awake to the issue ends up
distinguishing between Norte americanos
and other Americans with the term Gringo
which does have a derisive history I
believe the history is that it is a
reference actually to the color of
American money strangely
oh
um which is odd because of course it
would be very in Spanish yeah but um
nonetheless the point is whatever the
the etymology of the term by referring
to yourself as a gringo or if you're
referring to somebody who is not present
who you are looking for saying she's a
gringa or whatever it reveals that you
are sort of wandering off
not always I mean it's happened but
um but anyway you are revealing that
there is a kind of arrogance that often
goes with being a an American citizen
and that you are kind of aware that it
exists and anyway so in in communities
that are mixed uh between people from
Latin America and people visiting Latin
America the term Gringo has lost its uh
stigma and is simply used as a
descriptive term with a kind of a wink
yeah I think when we started going
together when we started traveling
together into Latin America that would
have our first trip
when we were you know barely in our 20s
would have been the early 90s
at that point certainly before going
down I would not have used the term
Gringo or Gringo about myself because it
felt like an epithet a slur and now I
now you I do yeah it is the way to be
clear when when you're there like yeah
you know oh that you know that
neighborhood's super grignified you know
that's that's where the tourists are
that's where the Gringos are like it's
it's become it's a normal background
it's become normal which also
um I mean there there's so many things
wrong with the style of thinking that
goes into a list like Stanford has
produced here but one of them is the
whole idea that one fixes Problems by
policing speech which does not mean that
there aren't terms that
feel like yeah that's off that shouldn't
that shouldn't be there
um but in general even in those cases
you are at best completing a job of
fixing something by deciding not to use
a term because there's something off
about it you're not solving a problem
and I don't know why it is that um
feeble-minded folks who are interested
in social justice and I am not
synonymizing those two things there are
many of us who are interested in
Justice recognize its social Dimension
but feeble-minded Petty social
justice-oriented folks in every
generation become obsessed with language
rather than understanding a language is
a tool right if I you know here's here's
an example pet peeve of mine
as I think I've talked about on Dark
Horse before I don't like talking about
Christopher Columbus because no such
person ever existed and we in general do
not translate names however if I want to
be understood I do not say Cologne day
right right Cristobal cologne may have
been the man's name but if I want to be
understood I will say Columbus Day and
then maybe we'll have a conversation
about why Columbus Day and Columbus Ohio
uh is an absurd Colombia Colombia right
the country any of this Colombia
um are a strange uh
abuse of language but
to be understood one uses the language
that you know if you say
um
a
you know on that list for example was
the horror of the term walk-in
appointment right because of course not
everybody can walk right
now if you try to come up with a term
you know a locomote in a point oh you're
welcome to locomote in
am I taking a train like you know well
and it doesn't I mean I
yeah I I responded to all of these
things in my sub stack this week and you
know you just you you quickly get to
Harrisonburg Harrison Bergeron
space reality space where
there will be someone
in existence or who has been in
existence or who could possibly be in
existence who can't do the thing that
you are trying to be inclusive about and
if it if inclusivity is actually the
highest or one of the highest goals
you're screwed there's no possibility
for awesomeness for excellence for
discovery for
for doing something different for being
unique right like uniqueness is the
thing that shall not be allowed and not
not just uniqueness but not even
majority isn't enough it needs to be
everyone or nothing or no one and right
and and oh God if you are let's say that
you are unable to walk
as many people are as
we may end up unable to walk one doesn't
know
this is the least of your problems I'm
not saying I can't imagine a case in
which I bristle at some term that's used
but if the point is there's actually no
there there have we solved a problem by
saying by purging the term walk-in from
our language no we have not you could
equally make the argument actually
walking around people who can't walk is
the real offense so we should all not
walk if we haven't established that
everyone present in every context is
able to join us should they so wish
right that's a that's as valid an
argument as the idea that you shouldn't
say walk-in appointment you know my
guess would be that if we actually were
able to just survey language that we
would find people who cannot walk using
the term walk-in appointment without
thinking about it themselves right can I
make a walk-in appointment you know can
I are walk-ins welcome right that kind
of thing right
um so anyway again the whole thing
amounts to a power grab masquerading as
an attempt to be good to people who are
disadvantaged this you it is people who
are not generally disadvantaged using
the disadvantaged as an excuse to wield
power over others yes
we have two things that are somewhat
distinct but before I've actually got
another list put out by the University
of Oregon that Stanford links to about
it for Trans trans words words that are
sort of over in trans space that we
should or shouldn't use and what they
mean and all of this but two things
first that I want to say on this topic
as I and I wrote about this
um in the sub stack this week
the new the new Newspeak
we were at a conference went back when
we were Evergreen professors where
I was engaging with the Title IX
compliance officer so it wasn't our
Title IX compliance officers so
thankfully I did not have to abide by
her injunctions
but I was she she clearly had a view of
her own role and responsibility that far
was was overreach rather extraordinarily
and she had this sense of if everyone
can't participate then no one can
participate
and so I was at that point I had already
done a couple and I think I was sort of
in the early days of putting together
and creating this 11-week study abroad
program that we then ran with our boys
and we had 30 students and it went all
over the place right in in Ecuador it
was but including the Deep the Deep
Ecuador on Amazon there was a sort of
shallow Amazonian place I call her
starter Amazon field site and then we
went deep into the Amazon and uh and I
said to this Title IX compliance officer
what uh what would you have had me do
had a student in a wheelchair said that
they wanted to participate in this
program
and she said well you would have had to
figure out a way to allow them to
participate
I said well you know it seems like the
wrong program for them but uh I could
you'd say that I would have to create
paperwork and you know assignments back
home so that while we're in the field
for 11 weeks which is a big chunk of the
Academic Year they're doing work back
and I said no no they have to be able to
go
I said to her my exact quote was the say
Amazon is not ADA Compliant you know if
it were it wouldn't be the Amazon
and she said well then
you'd have to cancel the program
and this this was so extraordinary like
I
I really thought that I had misheard her
and I pressed her a couple times she
said no you can't I mean if someone who
wants to go can't go then no one can go
so this is the end point of this
ideology that would keep a lot of people
who never had an opportunity to travel
at all from seeing frankly one of the
most miraculous and intensely
biologically gorgeous and educational
places on the entire planet
because someone who's confused about
their abilities has said they want to go
and can't
so
as if
denying these other people that
opportunity does the person who is
aggrieved any good if their spiteful it
does doesn't it well this helps the
spiteful it's about it's about power but
you know this is one of the things I
sometimes say about
constructing systems at work
is that you actually have to build if
the system is of any size you have to
build discretion into it right and so
what you need is someone to be able to
say well actually no good is done by a
shutting down your program in order to
accommodate somebody that can't be
accommodated by the thing that's in the
title of the program that you're going
to go do that they can't do right you
have to have somebody in a position to
make that judgment and you know even
from the point of view of the person who
can't go and wishes to be included and
upon finding they cannot be
uh included might spitefully want to see
the whole thing shut down the best thing
you can do for them is leave the program
intact and say I'm sorry there's no
there's no way to make an accommodation
here that would work right that is life
the education that one needs is yeah it
sucks there's certain things
and it's not as good a hand as some
other people in this regard right but
the question for all of us every moment
of every day is what's the best use of
the hand that I've got right right and
totally you know yes if somebody has
damaged the hand that you have you know
in a negligent fashion there is
something to be done right but the idea
that denying people who had nothing to
do with your disadvantage the ability to
do something that they have the skills
and the capacity to do is
um Preposterous I do remember a story
many years ago I think I watched it on
60 Minutes
somebody had invented and these things
now exist we've seen them I think in
Europe
um but a bathroom
that self-cleans a public bathroom like
a stainless steel bathroom that's
self-cleans in between each
yeah sprays the whole thing down with
bleach or something I don't know how it
works but it's a it's a miraculous thing
and it solves the problem of public
bathrooms become quite grotesque quickly
and I believe they were being installed
and then somebody sued because they were
not ADA Compliant and they were removed
and so the idea well how did denying
people who could have had access to this
bathroom helped the folks who wouldn't
have been able to use it it didn't it's
an obviously
um
illogical remedy in fact it's not a
remedy it's a non-remedy that solves a
dissonance yes right yes
um but you know yeah it doesn't solve
the dissonance it it pretends the
dissonance has no has no place in the
universe it just pushes off that
Discovery until another thing will
reveal that actually
if you are for instance wheelchair bound
you know there's there's no we're not
supposed to say disabled
wheelchair-bound all of these things
those are all in this list here right
that is
no doubt unfortunate and there are
probably also other things that you can
discover that you will be able to do as
a result of not having the the
locomotory powers that
um you either did before something
happened or you would have had you not
been born unable to move your legs
pretending
pretending doesn't help you
pretending that you actually have all of
the same
skills and capacities as everyone around
you who does have full use of their legs
is helpful to no one it's not kind it's
not helpful and this you know this
this may be the Crux which is that we
are told and so many
you know
good Liberals are compelled that what
you need to do
with regard to the trans stuff with
regard to this language stuff is to be
kind just be kind
just
do for the person what they ask you to
do for them it's how they feel it's
their identity like you know what
your kindness your attempt at kindness
is not only not a kindness to everyone
else often because you're actually doing
damage you do it destroying systems that
work and destroying the safety of women
and children and homosexuals and all of
this who are talking about the trans
stuff but
it's not a kindness to the person it's
not a kindness to them to pretend that
reality is not reality yeah it's the
opposite of a campus it is the opposite
of a kindness helping somebody to be as
able as they can be in light of whatever
cards they've been dealt is the right
thing and pretending that we can solve
their problem by policing everybody
else's behavior
um is uh is an absurdity yeah so there's
one other thing before I show you some
of this trans glossary
um I was thinking when we were talking
about language like wait a minute
excuse me I remember
I remember
hoping for an advocating for a language
change
when I was in my 20s
and
I think the thing that makes it
different is that I was hoping for I
wasn't the first by any means but I was
hoping to add something to the
repertoire rather than restrict or take
something away which is to say mids the
The honorific Miz Ms period because and
you know everyone who's thought about
this uh knows why but because Mr exists
as an honorific that doesn't specify
anything except the sex of the person
the fact that they're an adult it's it's
it's a man it's an honorific for a man
that doesn't uh imagine anything else
about him whether or not he's a doctor
whether or not he's married whether or
not he's you know anything right whereas
there was no until Miz there was no
honorific for a woman that is say an
adult human female
that didn't inherently specify whether
or not she was married Mrs or not
married Miss and so there was no
equivalent you had Mister which
basically and so Mr versus Mrs or Miss
tells us that the language as it existed
without an honorific for women that
didn't specify whether you were married
or not that somehow being married was a
fundamental thing that you needed to
know about a woman and uh and so you
know Ms Ms seemed and still does seem to
me to fill a gap that was that was
necessary and that revealed
past sexism in the language well I think
actually there are two structural
differences that argue in favor of this
one as an actual remedy and as an
addition as opposed to a right taking
away you weren't arguing that nobody
should be allowed to say misses or right
miss about themselves sure of course not
right so the point is there are contexts
in which women were not common or found
at all that women gained access to in
which their marital status was
specifically not relevant right and so
the idea that men had a term that didn't
convey this piece of information because
in a business context or scientific
context it was completely irrelevant
means that having access to a neutral
term that does not convey availability
as a fundamental is valuable so in
effect what you had is the previous
state of the language was a form of
compelled speech right you had to convey
marital status because you didn't have
an option that didn't contain it you
either
incorrectly right you could use misses
if you weren't married right nobody
could stop you from doing that but then
the point is that conveys a false piece
of information yeah right so
the idea that
the past version was coercive maybe in a
past World it made sense to allow that
because
this piece of information was relevant
in all contexts who knows but in a
liberated world where women are
participating fully in these venues
where marital status is utterly beside
the point you need that equivalent term
and so adding to the language giving an
option that is neutral and not
compelling the conveying of a piece of
information that's irrelevant both seem
to me to change this but it is the very
rare example of a linguistic change that
actually solves the problem a linguistic
change that is explicit and sort of
hoped for right like that's because
language doesn't language evolves
language isn't it generally doesn't get
changed from on high like this these
this misunderstands how language changes
know with each generation we have we
have new new phrases new ways of using
words and other words and phrases or
meanings fall out of use and that you
know that is what happens there will
always be someone who says oh I missed
that thing I really want this or like
how could we be you know abusing the
language this way like okay we can we
can get riled up about all these things
right but that is what happens to
language whereas this and ah you can't
do that like that's not how this works
and sometimes there can be a recognition
like with Miz of you know we're actually
missing a word yep our language is
missing a word and here we go
yeah actually you know what
that's another really good point is that
I'm drawing it too cleanly where
language evolves we agree on this but
architected changes are almost never
a good idea right that's not true if new
words come into being all the time and
they are often architected or have to be
architected because you've done
something technically new yeah right
like you know I'm sure the term
electronic did not exist electric
existed there were lots of motors and
things but then electronic had to be
invented as a term that connoted
something beyond that some kind of
processing and so anyway when you are
involved in the production of some new
capacity or technology or observation of
some pattern the ability to say if
you're literary like I mean Shakespeare
brought how many words of the language
right
I don't know but it's a lot a lot yeah
yeah
um but the I guess the point is when
there's something that new that needs to
be said and you don't have a word for it
architecting a word that conveys it as
well as possible is a good thing
um when you are trying to force a change
onto language that is already adequate
to convey everything you've got wow no
yeah it's it's not it's not the remedy
yeah that's right
okay let's look at a few more of of
these uh attempts at I mean this isn't
actually compelled speech this is the
transglosser you can show my screen if
you like here this is one of the links
that Stanford gave on its site for where
it sourced its where its source material
came from University of Oregon Human
Resources trans glossary 101.
um there's just four they're all they're
all interesting assigned sex
the Declaration here I'll make it a
little bit bigger with that
oh yeah I don't know what is going on
okay I forgot yeah now I thought I was
um
sorry no that's really not helping at
all so I'll just go back to where I was
and it's gonna be small for you guys
that's in our audience for momentarily
pleased at that change yeah
okay uh assigned sex the Declaration by
a medical provider of an individual sex
and gender is based on genitalia
appearance at Birth after the assignment
the individual is expected to grow up
and exist within a certain set of gender
roles appropriate to their assigned
gender commonly seen as female assigned
at Birth or male sign at Birth also see
sex
I don't know what in what way this is
right actually I think that they've made
as many errors as they possibly could in
a
a sentence a set of sentences this long
well I think it's right just you know it
assumes a many worlds interpretation of
physics in which there's a world in
which an obstetrician tells you what
gender you are and then hands you either
a truck or a set of cooking implements
depending upon the assignment you know
if that world exists then this is a
perfectly appropriate point to be making
I mean this I don't know when this was
made but it's up in the end of 2022.
a sexism assigned at Birth it's observed
to birth or before birth I've said it a
billion places at this point
um so just
that's point one but after the
assignment no it's not an assignment but
after the assignment the individual is
expected to grow up and exist within a
certain set of gender roles appropriate
to their design gender says who like
when are you living the 1950s what is
going on here like that's not that's not
the world that we were living in until
you yahoos decide to come in and decide
that if you felt like wearing lipstick
that must mean you're a woman like what
is happening wouldn't it be wonderful
though I would love to see a skit in
which the obstetrician declares the
child male and then the parents were
like oh good what what careers does that
open up for them
exactly this is so I just don't
understand how anyone can put a list
like this together and not the entire
time go God this is regressive God we're
going backwards oh this is bad like this
is so no freaking regressive but at some
level look we keep falling into this
right this is sophistry and the real
point of this list is not the content of
the list the real point of this list is
to see if you're afraid of them right if
you're afraid of them yeah then you will
start attempting to do these things if
you are not afraid of them you might
just go on speaking in ways that convey
things to people as if that was your
purpose yeah
okay next run from the University of
Oregon's uh trans resources list
cisgender privilege
um
cisgender of course meaning uh that uh
how you present to the world is the sex
that you are
the set of privilege and and I will say
before I read their cisgender privilege
thing uh I
will
call someone trans who is identifying as
trans
I have rejected from way back back when
we had trans students and I we were
thinking about this and wading through
it and all of this at one point a
student who was sort of dabbling one of
the cues you know queer questioning
something
um decided to tell the entire classes
another class that we were teaching
together but decided to tell the entire
class that all the rest of us
um needed to start a
introducing ourselves as CIS as
cisgender and I said no
no we don't that is that is not what we
are
sis is a word created by the tiny
minority to make it seem
that uh the world is not as it is so I
object to the term I I acknowledge that
if you're going to have trans that there
needs to be a a category to which to
compare it to but that doesn't mean that
the vast fast vast majority of us for
whom genetics and development went in
the normal way and who do not feel a
deep sense of misalignment between the
sex that we are and the sex that we feel
ourselves to be do not need to be
walking around saying I'm a CIS like no
we just taught her okay so cisgender
privilege they say the set of privileges
conferred to people who are perceived to
be cisgender examples having one's
correct pronouns used no harassment in
public restrooms no denial of Access to
Health Care
there's no denial of access to
healthcare thing is up there with if you
don't affirm your child's new Trans
identity they're going to kill
themselves that's it's right up there
with that it's it's this claim oh Trans
people are having their health care
tonight no
trans people
have not had any health care that is
available to all the rest of us ever
denied to them what in some places
people under some ages are being
restricted from having is
permanently misfiguring misfiguring or
hormonally disrupting procedures done
which no one who is not trans would ever
choose to have done right it's it's so
it's not about health care it's about
the thing that somehow you've decided
you should expect to have access to
because you have a condition that is
suddenly fashionable
it's not Healthcare it's exactly if you
identified as fentanyl deficient are you
entitled to have fentanyl distributed to
you exactly and the answer is no you're
not entitled to any such thing the way
we do medicine there are prescription
drugs this is one you can't have it
unless a doctor decides you need it
right and yet the you know the the
needle distribution stuff for heroin
addicts is you know not too far from
this right and yes it's
better to have clean needles than dirty
needles but it's better not to have
access to any needles at all and I you
know I'm I am not making a claim about
what I think should happen in that space
with regard to people addicted to drugs
that they shoot up but it is the same
kind of logic like well obviously the
thing you need to do is just give them
access to all the things that they say
they need
or
we could try to help them not be addicts
right we could Define what is you
hurting yourself and not help you do
that and just decide what kind of help
you might be offered now this is a
harder argument to make in an era where
our medicine has become so prone to
injure people as a matter of I don't
know
um doing pharma's bidding but
um but in a decent world you would you
would rig this in such a way that
doctors were a bias in the direction of
improving your health rather than
um you know maiming you because you had
a feeling yes
I will say cisgender privilege though
also is not a good term because it's
just ambiguous it sounds
um like your parents treated your sister
better than you
you know what I'm going to say
right it's spelled differently it spells
differently but yes it sounds it's only
spelled differently if you're spelling
yes true okay two more I don't know how
I won that point but I feel that I did I
mean the last point that you made was
true I don't know that counts as winning
but in my world yes very much so
um two more
two more from the University of Oregon's
trans resources you could show my screen
if you like Zach lesbian
I don't even know if the person writing
this knows how to write but lesbian a
person who self-identifies as a woman's
capacity to be emotionally physically
intersexually attracted to other people
who identify as women
wow
no this is not sure just just just
no
lesbian is someone who is an adult human
female woman
who is sexually attracted to other adult
human females women
not trans women
not people who emotionally feel like
women on the inside no uh-uh bra yeah
this one is easier to Define than
they're than they're letting on a lot a
lot and finally
uh sex
a term used historically and within the
medical field to identify genetic
hormonal physical characteristics
including genitalia which are used to
classify an individual as female male or
intersex
to also social behavior activity engaged
in by an individual with one of our
partners to express attractions and
arousal
a term used historically and within the
medical field archaic
500 million years guys
maybe closer to 2 billion okay that's
how long sex has been involved around a
term used historically sex
the word
has been around
probably about since language has been
around it was one of the first things
that people were using to categorize
other people but that's all irrelevant
this is from the people who really think
that if you don't have a word for it it
doesn't exist and they'll make that
argument too and some of them will say
no of course we don't think that but
then you see some of the crap they say
and like yeah the fact that the word has
or has not been abused or used or
changed meaning this that or the other
it doesn't matter because sex itself we
are part of a lineage that has been
sexually reproducing with two and only
two Sexes for at least 500 million years
maybe closer to 2 billion with a B
it doesn't matter historically medical
field this letter yeah there doesn't
matter wait I think we are missing a
term does not immediately spring to mind
what it might be but
in most cases a word means something and
then it may stop meaning that or it may
mean something and it may come to mean
something else right
the idea what's going to happen here
right you've got
whatever the nice term for morons is who
have decided that you shouldn't use the
term sex in the way it has been used to
refer to patterns that go back hundreds
of millions of years at least
it's not going to work
yeah we're going to go back to calling
it sex so what do you call the brief
period of time in which the morons have
disproportionate power such that a term
doesn't mean that thing it did mean it
and it will mean it but it doesn't mean
it right now the brief period of time
well hopefully we can just go at a Dark
Age and we don't have to call it the end
of civilization oh yeah it is it is it's
like a linguistic Dark Age yeah that's
exactly it
no that's exactly it all right good
oh it's fabulous no no it's good
the fact that you know a cognitive Dark
Age one in which you stop having science
publicly interacted over
um
is a recognizable phenomenon right
when we say Dark Age we do not mean it
will forever be dark right it might be
that this one brings Humanity to an end
but if Humanity continues we will go
back to doing science you know why
because it works yeah if Humanity
continues we will go back to referring
to sex in an intuitive way why because
it conveys something that we want to
convey with some regularity right
accurately because in this case as in
many cases but not in all cases our
Collective intuition is correct that sex
is real
yeah all right I I think this is ready
linguistic Dark Age is exactly the right
concept and uh and I don't think I don't
think it exists uh in our parlance and
we need it if they're gonna pull this
[ __ ] on us we need to have that term to
explain what they're doing good
um
shall we talk a little bit about this um
La magazine piece yeah absolutely all
right uh so Jeremy Lin quit Jeremy Lee
Quinn who you have interviewed yes on
Dark Horse uh he is a journalist maybe
you want to describe yeah he is a
freelance journalist who has done an
immensely good job of placing himself in
the place where history is unfolding
multiple times now he was actually on
the ground uh at January 6th among other
things right at the capital uh anyway he
he's interesting for a number of reasons
one he is exceedingly good at being
even-handed right his politics he wears
on his sleeve but they do not impact the
way he reports this when somebody's
being a fool it doesn't matter which
side they're on he he points to it and
describes it very well and he happens to
be far left right he's he described he's
far enough left he describes himself as
an anarchist when pressed on it he's not
simply an anarchist he has a a rather
nuanced understanding of anarchism in
his what way it might be positive I of
course disagree with him on this but
nonetheless
he comes from the far left
but he has he has critiqued left and
right with equal uh
uh with equal attention to detail in
recent times and uh so he he was on the
ground in Portland during our uh
meltdown
which person that call a backup
a nightly recurring Riot that goes on
for over 100.
um I don't know what you call it but in
any case he was he was there for that so
anyway he has continued to do this where
he figures out where things are
happening and he shows up and he
documents them and he's collaborated
with people whose bent is more of a
photographic and video nature in many
cases
anyway quite like the guy really like
what he's been doing you want to talk a
little bit about his uh his most recent
thing from La magazine yeah so uh he has
written this piece and you can just show
my screen I'll just read a bit from it
um called trans yeah there it is uh
exclusive transgender fugitive who
spurred we Spa riots Bears all Darren
merricker I don't know if I'm
pronouncing his name correctly the just
arrested Angelina who launched a
firestorm from a women's locker room
spoke with LA magazine while on the lamb
uh and so uh merricker again I may be
mispronouncing his name is now in
custody but he was not for something
like 15 months I think and while he was
not in custody and he was being looked
for uh Jeremy Lee Quinn sat down with
him and did this this interview uh which
is quite quite interesting so let's just
read so for those uh many people may
remember that in the early summer or
June of 2021 there's a spa in LA's Korea
town called the Wii Spa
it's not a women's Spa but it has like a
woman's floor and a men's floor and I
went on to their site I don't remember
there's like I've never been
um but there there are it's it's got sex
segregated spaces and there's also
non-sex segregated spaces but um the
locker room
um the locker rooms are sex segregated
and this dude walked into women's locker
room
naked and into the hot tubs I guess in
the women's segregated spaces
um you know penis out and got called to
account for it I think I think
um the first woman who said what do you
do in here actually she got escorted off
the premises first uh but then
ultimately
um he had uh indecent exposure charges
thrown at him and then he was a fugitive
from Justice for like 15 months so um as
Jeremy Lee Quinn writes it Darren
merricker the transgender Angelino at
the center of an indecent exposure row
that began in the summer of 2021 at a
Koreatown spa and then exploded into a
national Scandal has been arrested in La
after 15 months on a lamb
it was June 23 2021 at we spawn Wilshire
and South Rampart when 52 year old
merricker caused a near Riot by exposing
his or was it her penis to a locker room
full of women in September 2021 the LA
County D.A filed five felony accounts of
indecent exposure against mariger and
since the Arcadia native has been the
red hot center of a huge blow up over
trans rights
Okay so
a few and then he does this this
interview
Quinn does this interview with merricker
and it's quite
quite remarkable
he America goes to the protests that are
erupting about him okay but he goes as
himself which is to say he's a dude he
looks like a dude he just looks like a
dude and he goes and sits in his car
and uh
and he says I was first here we have I
was first contacted by a black female
who then went and summed a large group
to confront me it appeared to be a
mixture of antifa types as well as this
black and pink grip
he
continues that they thought that he was
a proud boy
because he just looks like this big dude
sitting sending in a an Escalade and
they say no you're a proud boy People
Like Us don't drive Escalades that's a
new rule apparently it's a sign of birth
you will or you will not have asked
access to Escalades yeah so now we know
that the people who were protesting on
behalf of this dude's right to expose
himself in women's locker rooms and in
women's Spas we're hassling him for
looking like a proud boy and Escalade
didn't believe that he was the
trans woman at the center of this well
wait wait I want to add something you
may be going there but
in the interview it's quite clear he is
under No Illusion whatsoever about
whether or not he looks like a man in
fact at one point in the interview he
says how would anybody know if I didn't
tell him right but this is not
a simple case of somebody gaming the
system
because well go ahead so let's just read
this section that I think you're
referring to here let's back up let's
back up a second Quinn says should we be
using male or female pronouns with you
how do you identify
he says I'm very neutral like non-binary
although I don't like that word I'm
legally female but I have facial hair I
have a penis I have no breasts I don't
have a feminine voice I don't wear
makeup or dress up like a female so
imagine you're a grocery store clerk and
you're bagging my groceries and you say
Excuse me sir I mean am I supposed to be
offended that'd be ridiculous how would
this person know but technically for
legal terms I am she her I put female on
my driver's license but I've had to
struggle my whole life fitting into
traditional Society
Quinn says and you sleep with women
you're a female who has heterosexual sex
with females
merricker merger whatever his name is
says I have heterosexual sex because my
penis fits in a vagina I don't tell
women I'm with that I'm transgender
because that's not my sex so I'm not
faking anything gender is internal sex
is external
he got his sex change changed He got His
official designation changed because
California law law now allows you to do
that just by saying I've decided I'm a
different sex he is being somewhat
precise in his language here but the
fact is that he is gaming the system
but he is he he is just making a claim
that he feels like a woman and he is
actually in no way in no way
in no way doing anything
um that appears to have him be be
woman-like even so so two more here
well okay it's sort of relevant to that
okay when I read that
um it created some sympathy for him in
my mind
and he loses that sympathy later on for
reasons we will get to but my sense is
okay on the one hand this is a person
who is certainly clearer about where
they are and what their expectations are
with respect to the world than most
folks if you were purely gaming the
system the idea that he has the right to
be called she by some clerk who has no
way of knowing might well be on the the
list of expectations here he's saying
look how would a clerk know there's no
outward sign this is about an inward
feeling but my point my point is this
this person is confused
most people are confused about many many
things a number of people who do not
have profound confusions running around
in their mind uh is very small at the
moment
I can't begrudge him
taking the world at its word that if you
feel differently inside saying okay I am
now female and going to the lengths of
changing your legal status
he
I don't see that as gaming the system I
see this as somebody who has taken what
he's told are the new rules of the
system and saying this makes sense for
me now this this strikes me as the most
obvious case of someone who has seen
what he can do he literally has
heterosexual sex with women he literally
he's he's a dude who likes to have sex
with women and he does and he doesn't
tell them that he goes and pretends to
be a woman because he got his legal
status changed in order to get himself
into spas and hang out with a bunch of
naked women like so that's that's what
he has gotten like that that is he gets
to walk around with and you know I don't
I as you know did not like to
play this card as it were but he gets to
walk around with the privilege the big
brawny men walk around with he gets to
walk around at night with a lot less
fear that oh my God I gotta make sure I
don't turn down that corner or down
where there's a street light out or this
side or the other because he's walking
around like a dude because he is a dude
right and then he and then because he he
had one legal thing changed as soon as
the law changed to California and now he
gets to go and swing his dick around in
a women's spot no but you're right that
that's Apollo the question is whether
what is appalling is that that is the
new set of rules or whether what is
appalling is his availing himself of
that rule I've had to struggle my whole
life fitting into traditional Society he
he says the right keywords there is
nothing here so he says
um was that something that was discussed
with your therapist Quinn asks how did
you come the decision to make the
appointment to go in to get the driver's
license changed this is the only thing
that's different for him right yep
he says our discussion basically started
around April 2017. between April 2017
and 2019 I had figured that evaluating
how I fit and how I had problems in
prison you come to the conclusion that
makes more sense where you're going to
fit better in life he's doing this
because he doesn't want to be in a Men's
prison the next time he's arrested for
being a criminal right perfectly
rational perfectly rational and having
not like why would you why would you
have compassion for a male criminal who
knows he's going to end up in prison
again for thinking ahead and putting all
the women prisoners at risk instead
because I believe in good governance and
I believe that it is Our obligation to
create a set of rules that is sensible
to have discretion built into the system
for edge cases don't just give me a look
like what is your problem yeah what is
your problem no the dog and I know
um
um
there are two questions here okay one
are you going to fault people for
utilizing the rules as they are laid out
to my way of thinking you have insane
people who somehow gained power to
change the rules that the rest of us
live by right those people are
despicable right they are involved in a
power game somebody who looks at the
rules and does what
they think matches best
he doesn't think it's what matches best
it means he doesn't have to go to a
Men's prison perfectly right he's gonna
and yes rational but having nothing to
do with whether or not he actually feels
like a woman he doesn't
well I don't know but you are a
convicted sex offender aren't you go and
asks him weren't you once caught without
pants and masturbating while peering
into the window of an 85 year old
Arcadia woman
so what happened was this elder the man
got to use the bathroom in the middle of
the night and his bathroom overlooks
another yard and he saw me masturbating
but even if it was masturbation I don't
have a problem with that because that's
not illegal it's only illegal if you're
masturbating in someone's face like
George Michael
a that's not an answer B he's despicable
yeah this is one of two places where he
lost my sympathy but I don't understand
how he had your sympathy at all he's
clearly clearly doing everything he can
to put himself in women's spaces where
he can be
criminal I like there's lots of words I
could say there but he he is he's going
to end up in a women's prison if he ends
up in prison again and there he will be
putting all of the women at risk I guess
he has no place in the women's prison he
has no place in London we both agree he
has no place in women's prison he has no
place in women's Spa
totally agree however the people who are
really at fault here are the people who
changed the rules so that a guy like
this has discretion but he also has no
he's no confusion he has no remorse he
says look I know I'm a dude I have sex
with with women because I mean he he
walks us through it right and then he
just says oh yeah you know because I
haven't fit in in life like everyone
doesn't fit in sometimes dude look you
may be right that he's gaming the system
and I don't necessarily detect it
nonetheless you've got two possible
worlds
you have a world
in which
we make
rules that make sense and everybody is
held to them or you have a world in
which dangerous people are allowed to
create a hellscape in which you have
choices you shouldn't have and they
decide who will be flagged for making
those choices and who will not right you
have monsters deciding on the rules of
sex and gender
silencing biologists and doctors and
anybody else who would dare speak up and
point out how insane this is and then on
the street they're saying here's how we
know you're full of [ __ ] you drive and
Escalade okay so no they approached him
because he looks like in their words a
proud boy right
okay but
he couldn't possibly no no
we have the same I'm going to forget the
name of the institution that was shot up
in the recent uh shooting that was
touted as a conservative shooting up a
trans space and then the guy turned out
to identify oh the Colorado Springs the
the queer bar outside of Colorado right
take a look at that here you've got a
situation in which a queer bar is shot
up you have everybody saying well this
is obviously anti-queer and then it
turns out that the person who did the
shooting identifies as queer and the
point is well we know he's not right you
are free to tell us whether you do or
don't identify but if you turn out to be
one of the ones we don't like then we
are in a position to say you're making
it up so I don't like a world in which
discretion has anything to do with this
right but I mean I guess
it's all discretion no it's not all
discretion the fact is
if
the monsters are going to make a rule
that says hey if you tell us you're
female you're female if you say you're
trans you're trans right if they make
that rule they have to live with the
downside of that argument okay but so I
don't know where this guy falls I don't
know he could be pure monster and he
could be have no gender confusion no
strange feeling inside of him be saying
that because it's the right thing to say
it's perfectly possible and it's
consistent with a couple of things in
this article or he could be somebody who
is looking at the rules as they are laid
out and saying actually in light of the
rules this is what I am
I don't I don't buy it for a second not
with this guy
um what one more segment here
to read
he
he is saying
that someone a guy a a trans woman I
guess
who goes by Bambi Salcido I may be
mispronouncing that
um
is I guess I'll just read this and you
can show my screen if you like Zach
um just while I'm reading it you mean
Bambi Salcido Quinn writes president and
CEO of the trans Latin at Coalition the
largest translate organization in LA
she said in a story about you you'd
think after getting arrested a bunch of
times she just changed clothes in a
stall
so Bambi does refer to this guy as a she
yes and the big guy whose name I keep
forgetting says right so in the article
she says she goes to we spot three times
a year and she gets naked in there she
never has a problem
so I spoke to Bambi Salcido on the phone
before the story came out she admitted
to me that she has boobs and she takes
off her top that she does not take off
her bottom was because she has a penis
nobody knows she's transgender
Quinn says nobody knows you're
transgender and you have a penis what's
the difference
that is to say
people read him as male because he's
male and why do you call Bambi a
supposed transgender person Quinn asks
we can go into that but if she
surgically altered parts of her body
that's transsexual I know that's a
controversy in and of itself but I can
explain that
Quinn says are you saying that
transitioning either hormonally or
physically somehow disqualifies someone
from being authentically transgender
and he says you have to understand
gender identity everybody's confusing
you're internal with your external all
these external people are doing what is
being called transitioning there's no
transition that's called deviation I'm
tired of that word transitioning it's a
fake word that people like Bambi use the
whole point is this is how you are born
so and this is the guy
and
he's saying that people who are actually
living this with Downstream consequences
for themselves who are actually having
the surgery and the hormones
are a different kind of thing and he's
the real deal because he's just a dude
who likes to go naked into women's
spaces and be a nightmare I've said he's
confused and he doesn't belong in these
spaces yeah I don't think there's any
confusion here hold on
you and I have said
that in fact trans is a very rare but
long-standing thing and that what is
highly unusual is that we have now taken
technology and decided that if you are
trans in the sense that you have this
profound dysphoria or whatever the
defining characteristic is that you are
entitled to modify yourself in with
technological help right and the point
is you have a long-standing something
that appears to Exist Elsewhere and then
you have a modern medical something and
the question is what is the relationship
now I don't like this guy's argument if
people are actually trans and they have
this profound dysphoria and then they
make a decision to modify themselves I
don't see that anything about their
psychological state is lost so I don't
see why he would exclude them from the
category but his point is the fact of
whatever the psychological state is is
distinct from the physical modification
well I think and maybe maybe and this
gets to the next piece that we're going
to talk about but um
he thinks that gender identity is real
as do all the trans rights activists
confused gender identity isn't real and
like everyone it seems who reads now the
New York Times and Martian post and NPR
is told that they really have to accept
the gender identity is real or else
they're transphobes well I'm sorry no
like gender exists in non-human animals
and sex exist in almost every life on
the planet right gender as the software
to the hardware that is sex as in an
animal that can move around the behavior
the behavioral ramifications of the sex
that you are
this guy's position
I have seen nothing and this is the only
piece I've read about him
um but there is nothing anywhere in this
piece that indicates anything about him
actually feeling like a woman like I
don't there's no evidence that he
actually has the confusion in any way
right he just went to the DMV at the
point that it became legal to do so and
said I know
I know what I can do I can continue to
walk around and have sex with any
straight woman will have me as the band
that I am but then I also now get to
enter women's spaces
so he gets it both ways and isn't that a
dream for him okay so one one more one
more little section from this yeah okay
um so one more section Zach let's get
back to we Spa Quinn says what brought
you there that night
I re-injured my back in an unprovoked
attack in Malibu
and I went to Wii Spa because it's the
only place in town you can get hot and
cold treatment which is one of the best
therapies you can get for
anti-inflammation
were you living near Koreatown no I was
in the neighborhood my local pool in the
marina was closed for maintenance
did you go to Wii Spa often no I've only
been there twice I had to do physical
therapy every couple of days and I roam
a lot
everything in that interchange says
Predator to me unprovoked attack in
Malibu
oh it's about the hot and cold treatment
but he didn't go to his pool which
wouldn't have had either of those oh
because it was closed for maintenance oh
we don't live near there I just roam a
lot like this guy is just like every
female Spidey Sense part of me yep it's
like oh no you you keep this guy out of
women's prisons out of women's faces out
of every Everything having to do with
single sex spaces for women
zero disagreement about that of course
my point is the most dangerous people
are the people who would set up a rule
where this is a question I'm not
defending them well but
in effect you are ending up in the same
place that they are where the point is
look you're female if you say you're
female unless we say you're not I'm not
in the same places then well in some
sense you're you're you're not in the
same they never should have set that up
and this guy who's who looks like a
predator is taking advantage of it and
you know I just just you know right
arguments about bad tax laws that allow
rich people to not pay enough taxes and
some honorable rich people say you know
what I am simultaneously going to take
advantage of the of the tax laws that
shouldn't exist so that I don't have to
pay as much taxes because I'd be foolish
not to but I'm also going to work to
change those tax laws so that we can get
a better world right right this this is
just a predator taking advantage of a
really bad situation which was created
by activists it was created by activists
but the point is those activists de
facto position is you're female if you
say you're female unless we say you're
not and they say he's not okay so I
don't like accepting the second part of
that formulation the point is the only
place to solve this issue is at the no
you're not female if you say you're
female now you may have to set a
standard given that there are
transsexuals we do have to figure out
what the standard is that decides
whether or not your driver's license
declares you female I mean how crazy is
it if you don't look female the idea
that your driver's license says you're
female is not about how you feel it's
about how to pursue you if you commit a
crime right it's a description of you so
that we know who you are if you're you
know car rolls over and we need to
identify you if you've committed a crime
and we need to find you it's totally
insane we just had we just got uh
submitted a passport renewal for one of
our sons this week
uh and now you can put X down you can
choose m for male f for female or X for
either other or doesn't want to have
said declined to say you shouldn't be
able to say that on your passport your
passport you should not be able to say
that on your passport right of course
not of course not so anyway my position
is look there is no excuse for this guy
being in these spaces but
the idea that there's a rule that says
you are what you say you are right but
but acknowledging that this guy's a
predator who's behaving extraordinarily
badly is not is not giving cover to the
people who helped create the rules
well but the problem is that
because this guy does not look female
right because he's not
yes but some people do look female who
are not
yeah okay and they're also not right but
the point is there is a part of this
that's like there's nothing female about
this guy right and the answer is
unfortunately these insane people have
created a rule in which that doesn't
matter
right and so it's as you know I'm not
arguing for this guy's discretion to go
into the women's spot right what I'm
arguing is that the insanity is that
we've created a rule and what these
people have done is they have created an
exception to the rule that they don't
even spell out
right who are you to question this
person's sex
uh I'm a biologist right doesn't count
doesn't matter biology says sex isn't
binary okay they're the only Arbiters
they create a rule and they're the only
averages I I agree that that's insane
but the fact that I come in this
particular case that I end up agreeing
with them doesn't make him anything less
of a predator well I mean look you don't
know for sure what what he is or isn't
um
like he's Quinn asks him several direct
questions like he's been in prison for
uh
he's a convicted sex offender because he
was masturbating while peering into the
window of an 85 year old Arcadia woman
the guy says
yeah but I was masturbating that's not
illegal that's not an answer and it was
illegal he like
oh okay so there's a question creep is
nowhere close to strong enough work this
creep is nowhere close to Strong Enough
totally agree on the other hand you know
all of the creepy [ __ ] that exists in
porn now right the fact is there's like
we're talking about this guy no we're
talking about we've got an industry
which caters to creep okay absolutely
okay so the point is being a creep ain't
illegal he's right about that okay I
don't know what the situation was with
the window whether he was breaking the
law or not presumably he was because he
was convicted but my point is
Western Civilization has a problem with
this exact concept right it does not say
creepiness is unacceptable it says
actually true it's monetizable okay so
this is true in a world where creepiness
is on the menu and your gender is what
you say it is because a bunch of crazy
people have gained enough power to make
that the rule I don't want to place that
at this person's doorstep nor do I want
to assume that I know what he's getting
out of it yeah I assume he's getting
sexual gratification from being naked in
front of a bunch of women that he's not
really entitled to be naked in front of
but why is he there because a bunch of
insane [ __ ] change the rules so that
we can't enforce anything that makes any
sense so maybe
what your position is the part of your
position that I wasn't seeing before is
I Brett see most of what you Heather are
seeing in this article
but
I don't see evidence that this is the
worst of what is being produced by the
system that they're actually like this
looks pretty clear-cut but there
actually are some ambiguities but
there's a whole lot of place where there
appear to be ambiguities where there
actually aren't and we need to be
thinking system-wide about and as we are
but we need to be thinking system-wide
about how depraved We are Becoming right
we have to think about how depraved We
are Becoming and frankly at a game
theory level this isn't hard there's one
place to solve this problem and it has
to do with the rules and yes you may
need some discretion for edge cases but
the one place to solve this is to make
an unambiguous rule about who is and is
not allowed to join the sport to go to
this prison to join this women's space
okay that's the place to solve it
there's no other place that is even
remotely viable yeah and you know
actually it occurs to me and this is
something we've talked at before but I
it never quite
occurred to me before to think that
actually their language around what
happens when the doctor sees you for the
first time if you didn't have uh
ultrasound or amnio or something and so
your sex hadn't been observed before
birth
at the point that your sex is observed
at Birth and there's is assuring us that
it's a sign that moves reality into
um
into this space of discretion that that
takes reality from reality to
discretionary space and so once reality
is discretionary then everything is
discretionary like it's it is stolen
from us the part where like no actually
there's a there's a base truth here
dude's a dude and in in this case he's
not even trying and in other cases they
are trying and it doesn't matter still a
dude yep so I before we go on to a case
that does show what the worst of this
looks like yeah
um I want to make one other point and
it's going to be a little hard for many
people to grasp why it's related here
okay but
years ago I gave this tedx talk on the
personal responsibility Vortex and the
basic point is there are two kinds of
systems in the world there are systems
in which the cleanup is done by the
benevolent people
those systems evolve towards being
ruthless and there are systems in which
the ruthless pay the cost of cleaning up
the system and those systems evolve
towards benevolence you can adjust the
rate at which you evolve in these two
directions but you're one side of the
line or the other so the idea that the
place to enforce this is but are you
really trans right this is discretion
and we're going to doubt you in all of
that creates a hellscape right in which
this is all going to be done based on
selective enforcement and people's
judgment and who has the power the only
place to create a system
you won't get everything you want out of
the system you won't protect every
single person who's in need of
protection but the way to protect the
maximum number of people from the
various harms that actually threaten
them is by structuring rules that are
themselves sensible and then
adjudicating those cases in which you
cannot easily apply the rule using some
sort of discretion where we know what
the law was trying to do when we say
here's the best we can do in this case
right so
what I'm getting at is the hellscape in
which this is discretionary is the one
in which the good people pay right and
just as we don't want to create tax law
that's vague and have people you know
abide by it on their honor we want to
create tax law that's utterly
unambiguous and make it so that the
people who pay are the people who
actually violate the rules right this is
a case where you want good rules
and then you want them enforced utterly
without prejudice right and
um we're headed in the other direction
because
dangerous people and their simpleton
Partners have engineered a set of rules
that you know a child could game
yeah right yeah
okay so yeah you alluded to this other
piece which
I'm not sure that I actually
oh I guess I do have a few things
um highlighted in here
you can show my screen here for a moment
and then I'll have you take it off while
I find the highlighted bits
uh this you shared with me this is
written by a woman named Mandy
statmiller I think well rabbit hold70
number 78. Dana reverse is the story the
media doesn't want you to read
uh this is a story unparalleled in media
censorship about deadly white male
violence against a lesbian interracial
couple in their black son when the media
goes silent there is always a reason why
um
Mandy gives a trigger warning in this
piece you give me a trigger warning when
you shared it with me which I almost
never do you don't yeah
um and it this the story warrants it
this is
this is so horrifying you really can't
imagine
what is going on but the the the very
thumbnail version is that this guy
um
uh started you know claim claims to be
trans started invading women's spaces
including uh for instance this um I
think it's called Mitch Fest the I may
have this wrong but the the famous and
long-lasting Women's Music Festival in
Michigan that was held every summer
until these
trans women started invading it with
violence and aggression and all of this
and they basically had to shut it down
so you know and yet another example of
women's spaces not being allowed to be
one of the spaces because people who
aren't women get to say they're women
and somehow you're not allowed to say no
you're not
this man is so full of rage and
particularly at one of the women in this
interracial lesbian couple
uh that he showed up at their house and
he he killed both of the women and their
19 year old
um son who happened to have been adopted
as I think a baby from Africa he had
just graduated from high school he was a
stellar student he was yeah he was going
on to great things and
um he slaughtered all of them and the
the
number of things that he did to the
woman whom he hated most as he killed
her are extraordinary
we've not heard about this story that's
the other story what we did hear about
apparently and I don't remember this but
what Mandy
um the author of this piece reports is
that this guy Dana Rivers
was lauded in the liberal media back in
the 90s when he first came out as trans
and uh was was just a media darling for
a while for being so brave
and the fact is that uh
you know he never really passed and so
women who saw him coming into women's
faces would say things to him
and uh on some of those women he took
out his rage to such a degree that um
they're now dead
brutally so and he is likely to be like
he took away the iPad or something of
the of the young man who he killed and
he was still wearing it on his person
when he turned himself in so you know
there's really no ambiguity about
whether or not he committed these crimes
but because of new law in California at
the point that he's convicted he's going
to go to women's prison
yeah it's really you know and we pointed
out
years ago at this point
um that this was the danger that you
know we're talking about all kinds of
things that are yes horrifying like the
fact that men can now compete against
women in women's sports
um but the you know the deep end of the
pool really is prison right at the point
that somebody can decide that they go to
a women's prison irrespective of what
they've been convicted of
um irrespective of what uh kinds what
phenotype they have just show my screen
here these are the people who were
killed
people um but you know this is an a
completely unfudgable issue right the
fact is men who are capable of raping
women should not be in a women's prison
now in this case you've got a guy who is
not only physically enabled as a man he
still retains his penis but he is
obviously there's so many quotes in this
thing that make it clear that this is
the most deeply misogynistic person
right in fact there's one violently like
rape fantasy that he published as porn
on Amazon and some of it is still up yes
multiple
books that he is self-published on
Amazon that contain just the most
twisted and bizarre the most extreme
anti-female kinds of
or some sex rape violent fantasy stuff
that the idea that any Court would do
anything other than look at him and say
no dude
um you're you're going to a maximum
security Men's prison is uh you know
that's the only rational thing to do
with somebody this depraved and
dangerous that's right um and
the fact I mean I really see this as two
stories one there is the terrifying very
awful story that Mandy stepmiller has
written here yeah
and then there's the story of the fact
that it's not being covered yeah right
you are being told we are all being told
that trans is an important issue and
that in order for justice to Prevail we
must provide
the right to self-define yeah okay then
some of us say well
in principle you should have the right
to self-define until you get to the
place where that's a threat to other
people's rights and then there's
something that absolutely has to be
discussed oh really you you know you
really want to keep these people from
enjoying the protection of a space that
matches their internal uh sense of
themselves yes no I'm most worried about
prison like let's go to the person but
also of course women are allowed to have
women only spaces men are allowed to
have mentally spaces of course but my
point isn't that that's an ambiguous
case my point is we have a perfectly
unambiguous case there is no argument to
be made that a person like this
belongs in a women's prison because he
says so well really you think somebody
would identify as female just to go to a
women's prison yes I do and I've said so
before this case became public right
well and that's I mean the the other guy
from the Wii Spa thing you know he he
says as much in his answer this is part
of why I I feel pretty very confident
about my assessment of him is he says
well you know I've just really felt this
way and also prison wasn't a good match
for me like of course course Men's
prison is a good match for you I don't
it's a good match for just about anyone
right like
it's not that that was it's just so so
obvious a thing to say and to think that
that's like well that must mean I'm a
woman Inside It's like no that means
prison sucks but
but I'm trying to get at this other
point which is okay
people on side a
said in order to be just in order to be
kind in order to be decent we must carve
out the space to self-define then some
of us said that is going to cause you
problems when you get to things like
women's sports women only spaces women's
prison and they said no it won't because
that would require somebody to identify
as female in order to game the system
yeah happens all the time really no it
doesn't happen you're exaggerating how
often it happens hey take a look at this
the most horrifying story of a violent
sexually motivated Murder by somebody
who just happens to have published
several self-published several books you
know in which he explores these kind of
depraved fantasies
so this is the end of that argument
except it took Mandy's stepmiller to
write it on her sub stack in order for
us even to have access to the case
because the point is the system is now
so biased in favor of this argument that
it will actually obscure a case like
this and in fact it's been now uh at
least
many days since I read it so I don't
remember if I've got this exactly right
but
um
oh what was I going to say the uh
I've now lost it uh it'll come back okay
uh let me read a couple things yeah and
I'll come back to you sure
to paraphrase spiked online how you
identify as a man matters about as much
as whether you feel like your
criminality is actually Justified and
fully righteous because all the women
you've assaulted deserved it
imagine if serial killers and child
rapists could start identify could start
to identify as being innocent and that
was respected too
identity is an insult to the brutality
of reality
reality is that almost 100 of those
convicted of sexual violence are male 98
to be exact in UK prisons almost half of
those who identify with synthetic sex
identities identities have been
convicted of sexual offenses
incidentally the phrase synthetic sex
identities is excellent and that is um
that is what is being used here to
indicate those who are trying to pass is
the sex that they are not
there is not a female prisoner on Earth
who deserves the punishment of being
housed with Dana Rivers a psychopathic
Revenge obsessed male who has already
taken the lives of two women in their
family I ask you how many more women
does Rivers have to kill before all the
requests to be kind becomes a little too
much for all of us to bear
so yeah I do have it
um
two things one let us just notice that
the fools who have engineered our new
system
um
their logic
right that in fact even you know we've
used these same cases before but Caitlyn
Jenner did not win the men's decathlon
right Bruce Jenner did it is absurd to
have a system in which we cannot talk
about Bruce Jenner's you know it is
perfectly valid to say Bruce Jenner won
the men's decathlon later transitioned
to become Caitlyn Jenner who identifies
as female that is all factual but we're
not allowed to say it because of this
phony concept of dead naming now here's
the thing right this absurd idea that
you should be able to identify as
innocent is actually perfectly logically
consistent with the idea that dead
naming is a problem
correct sentence again the idea that you
could identify as innocent to escape
responsibility for a crime is perfectly
logically consistent with the idea
um that it is wrong to dead name uh
Caitlyn Jenner by talking about her
Olympic Triumph is Bruce right the point
is if you can forbid us to talk about
the actual manner in which you won some
award in the past then you can also walk
away from a crime that you've committed
because you are now identifying as
somebody different this is a new person
that person is dead oh yes he committed
a crime but he is now dead right that is
nonsense is there any chance I would not
have expected to find myself steel
Manning any part of their argument but
is there any chance
um but they are a little bit confused
by the fact that for some crimes intent
does matter
right that murder and manslaughter are
actually different crimes even if the
effect on the person who's been murdered
who's been killed is the same
I don't I don't quite get your argument
I would say intent always matters right
there is gross negligence but it's very
different but you're you know
I don't care if you think you're
innocent if you're not you're not
I do care a little bit if you were
trying to kill that person as opposed to
if you weren't killing that person
because it says some different things
about your mental state and who you are
as a human being and what your
likelihood is of doing such a thing
again in the future right I mean what so
I I guess because intent is a feature of
the Mind
it does take it into the space of well
I'm just creating it like this is just
this is this is something that bubbles
up from my mind and therefore maybe all
reality is like that okay that's that's
what I'd be more sympathetic to the
steel Manning if the very people who
would be uh confused in this way were
not also the people who claim intent
doesn't matter right so the
they make that argument and so uh it it
certainly is not exonerating here but
the other thing that is true is look
even if we Steel Man their gender
position your gender identity died with
that past name and this new name that
you have identified with is your new
gender identity there is nothing in the
world that says that you're murderous
Persona died with your gender identity
right if you're a person prone to murder
if you're a person who hates women I
don't care that you do or you don't
identify as one my expectation is you
didn't give up your hatred of women
because you suddenly identified as one
and in fact there's a terrible I think
it is at this Festival that you were
describing where this guy is terrorizing
lesbians at at this music festival but
at some point
he is he is assaulting some woman and he
says something like you know real men a
real women have [ __ ] or something it's
right here a flyer one particularly
revolting flyer left for lesbians
featured a man with a synthetic sex
identity on the cover who's a wrecked
penis dominated the page underneath the
words real women have [ __ ] yeah so
anyway the point is I don't I don't
really care even if the guy who
genuinely did identify as female the
point is he's got a murderous rage at
women and the the whole idea of you know
dead identity doesn't make
um any sense but
the point I had forgotten earlier
was it in this piece it is also clear
that many people who are ideologically
committed to this fantasy world in which
your gender identity is something you
are just free to embrace at any moment
and walk away from your past life
there's a point at which this man's
crimes have been revealed and there are
gender activists who are
making excuses for him and in fact
there's a question somebody says
somebody is quoted as saying well I
don't want to judge him for what he's
done until we know what these people did
to him that's right right and it's the
most bone chilling rationalization
you've ever heard right the guy has
flown into a murderous rage and killed
three people a lesbian couple in their
their son this is this is a former
teacher right he's also a former teacher
so
this is not somebody who's so mentally
disabled that he doesn't know what he's
doing this is somebody who
Delights in this stuff and writes about
it and in any case the idea that will we
shouldn't want to pass judgment on this
person who is you know uh
I I hesitate to recount how horrifying
what he did to these people is but the
idea that we shouldn't pass judgment
until we figure out whether they did
something that might have in some sense
Justified this uh I'm sorry no just
because this all flies in the face of
the stupid story you told us about how
safe it would be for everybody to
self-identify their gender you know on a
whim right this is the story that says
that's not true and now you're not going
to report it in the New York Times in
the Washington Post and all of the other
places that it should be discussed
really you're not going to report it and
when it is discussed in other circles
you're going to make excuses for this
person like
how wrong you know no you were wrong you
were wrong in the first place and we are
entitled now these people had to die in
order to prove that we were right that
this was a danger no no they shouldn't
have had to
they were they were innocent
yeah and they were living
they were living lives that benefited
from the some of the great successes of
liberal advances of the 20th century
right this was a
black and a white woman living together
in love having adopted a black son whom
they raised to be an excellent young man
and they're all dead
and
the race of the dude who killed them
shouldn't matter at all but all of these
people who would have us believe in the
Progressive stack and that the more
points you have against you because of
historical Injustice the more right you
have to speak
the white dude who slaughtered these
three people brutally
is being protected by the media
because he pulled the trump card that is
I call myself a woman
not even a woman we don't care about
women anymore a trans woman I call
myself a woman
I'm a dude I call myself a woman that
trumps everything else
and it's the one of them that you can
100 opt into
on a whim
it's all it takes I now call myself I'm
I'm gonna call myself a man call
yourself a woman anytime you want
California's facilitating it
other states presumably will follow
surely there are people who are part of
this
who can see this
and who have some power to help reverse
it
to the extent that there are monsters
it's the category they will end up in
because it is entirely discretionary by
these new insane rules and you know this
is obviously you know I I was
um
I I think it's hard to be a decent human
and be prepared for what's described
here and you know Mandy in her
description she wasn't prepared to write
it yeah um
it's it's that horrifying but I think
you know sometimes I also say
um that to make compassionate policy
requires dispassionate analysis this is
something there's another formulation of
it that I think was written before I
ever said that which I didn't know about
but anyway I don't want to pretend that
I made that up
I think if it was new with you but it
was new to me but somebody else had said
something so similar that it Bears
mention and I wish I remembered who
exactly it was but
that aside
the point is this requires a
dispassionate analysis A dispassionate
analysis says you know what
the hypothesis was if you changed the
rules in this way people would take
advantage of it people who were
specifically
um not interested were specifically
interested in utilizing the change in
the rules because of their rage at women
because of a desire to take advantage of
this category and this
is the proof that that's true you don't
get to hide it right
an honest analysis would say this is the
exception and not the rule which may be
true this exception proves why we cannot
have a rule that allows such exceptions
but you don't get to pretend it didn't
happen right by not writing the story or
by making excuses for this person
especially and but apparently you do
yeah well apparently you do apparently
you do get to pretend it didn't happen
but that that is part of why uh in this
this season when it would be great not
to be talking or thinking about any of
this we have we have spent our time here
today talking about some some true
Horrors
um that are one of the downstream
effects of the place that we started you
know with you know Stanford's list of
bad words seems trivial in comparison
but
this leads that leads to this
yeah
it does if if you've really become
confused about whether or not you're
assigned sex at Birth
uh or
I mean in the using the word seminal is
offensive like
yeah
the people making these lists and
policing them and making their living
doing this kind of thing
really need to build something with
their hands
or
plan a long
hike like a week
better a month three months go somewhere
outside of the country that you were
born in somewhere very different
language that you don't speak and
culture and food that you don't know and
make a go of it like experience things
that you can't
socially manipulate yourself into
convincing yourself that you got this
because if these are the kinds of lists
and policies you're making you don't got
this you're really confused
yeah I would I would add one thing to it
there's a general change in the way we
make policy now
and the general change is an argument
carries the day
we ignore why it carries today why did
this argument about gender identity
carry the day
because of power it was not a good
argument ever but it carried the day
because of power but here's the thing
that really troubles me
how much evidence would you need before
you realized that there was something
wrong with the argument to begin with
right a rational entity
pulls out of a nosedive right at some
point it becomes clear that the
instrument that said you were flying
horizontally is wrong and you ignore it
and you pull out of the Dive Right we
are now in a situation where the wrong
argument gets to win no matter how much
evidence accumulates that it wasn't a
good argument in the first place and
this is now true effectively across the
board right okay
you inoculated how many people with this
thing which didn't do what you said it
did and did a lot of things that you
told us it didn't do right at what point
do we we're not talking about literal
inoculation we're talking about literal
inoculations at what point do we get to
say you know what the amount of evidence
that what you told us about these things
was wrong in every regard is now so
great we're not listening to what you
say about whether or not it's still
something we should be giving to people
because you turned out to be wrong right
and
this is now happening on every topic
right the people who had the power to
get their argument to carry the day in
spite of the fact that they didn't know
what they were talking about
get to be right in the end even if all
of the evidence says they weren't right
somehow they are entitled to be right
rather than advancing these things as a
proposal the point is oh they've already
concluded that they were right and the
evidence will have to be refigured in
order that they get to retain that
status of being right they were right to
begin with they remain right and it's
it's nonsense logic has never worked
this way this this has to be the flavor
of this new dark age because that's the
only case in which you would not allow
the actual evidence to change your
position right the position is what it
is for reasons that have nothing to do
with what's true
that's right
all right I think we're there I think we
might be yeah uh we're gonna take a
break and come back with a q a
and if you don't hang around for that
we'll be back on New Year's Eve
uh our producer has his head in his face
in his hand so I hope okay this is real
good
um
flew back on New Year's Eve with our
last live stream of the Year there'll be
an episode of Dark Horse
it was Brett interviewing a guest to be
announced released next week and uh but
before we see you next unless you tune
in for the Q a in 15 minutes uh we're in
the middle of Hanukkah and Christmas is
coming up and the solstice has just
passed if you are in the northern
hemisphere as most of you are the days
are finally very very slowly beginning
to get a little bit longer although they
are will also be getting colder for a
while
happy continuing Hanukkah
happy ongoing Hanukkah to everyone Merry
Christmas when you finally get there and
Happy New Year's Eve to the X I don't
know something
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside
[Music]